فيما زميله في المهنه تبوء كورس رئاسه
لاداره بلاده في زمن الحرب فان سري
بريتولا يمسك بدفه المساعدات بقاعده
جمهوريه كبيره تمكن الممثل الكوميدي ومقدم
البرامج التلفزيونيه من جمع مئه مليون
دولار لشراء معدات عسكريه لبلاده منذ بدء
الحرب احدثوا مساهمته تمثلت بشراء مسيرات
كيميكاسي يصل مداها الى اكثر من 950 وخمسه
وستين كيلومتر وتستخدم لضرب اهداف بالعمق
الروسي قدره استثنائيه في جمع التبرعات
استخدمها الممثل الاوكراني لتحصيل 20
مليون دولار لشراء ثلاث طائرات بدون طيار
من طراز برقراب معجبوه جمعوا الاموال في
يوم واحد ما اثار اعجاب الشركه التركيه
المصنعه فقررت الاخرى تقديمها مجانا لك
ير انفقت لاحقا على شراء اول قمر صناعي في
اوكرانيا نزولا الى طلب وزير الدفاع الذي
وصف بالغريب حينها واتاح الوصول الى شبكه
من 15 قمرا اضافيا توفر للجيش الاوكراني
تغطيه مستمره في الوقت الفعلي للصراع في
شبكه ساهمت في تدمير اكثر من سبعه الاف
قطعه مختلفه من المعدات الروسيه وفقا
للمخابرات العسكريه الاوكرانيه زار
بريطانيا مرتين العام الماضي لشراء نحو
100 مركبه مشاه قتاليه كلفتها نحو سته
ملايين دولار امريكي مشكل اكبر عمليه شراء
فرديه للدروع على الاطلاق وجمع تسعه
ملايين دولار في اكتوبر الماضي لتامين
التدفئه بعد تكثيف موسكو لضرباتها على
البنى التحتيه للطاقه في اوكرانيا
اكد ان مؤسسته تشتري المعدات فقط نافيا
امتلاكه اي راي في استخدامها او تسليمها
مباشره الى الجيش اشار ايضا بترو توازن
كان زميلان منذ عام 2001 جمعتهما مهنه
التمثيل وايضا الطموحات السياسيه معانيه
تاسيس حزب وحلم البقاء
على قيد الحياه حتى النصر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات